speaking of history oh speaking of
history oh yeah this this is interesting
was Beethoven black huh you know what I
gotta be honest I don't really care yeah
that's what I said yeah
why what does it matter his music me
great music he's glorious it doesn't
matter if what your color of your skin
is if you do something amazing I want to
I want to give you props for it now
that's true and what is it saying that
hue controls the past controls the
present and who controls the present
controls the future what is that from
1984 is it it is yeah I don't forgot the
quote right it might be that is 100%
from 1984 was the past control as the
president he controls the present
controls the future yes some version of
this yes I think got it you know yeah so
hmm there where is this even found where
were they coming up with this so this is
this is actually listed on a ton of
verified news outlet sources talking
about that maybe they changed his race
because it was racist back then and he
was actually black were there to be
honest and to be I probably making it up
here's a story on it from me Oh calm was
Beethoven black bizarre post claims
composer was african internet says
history is being whitewashed according
to a picture being circulated on the
internet beethoven may have been a black
man and not the white men we have seen
in this portraits now here's my
prediction first thing we see is the
question could it be true and then once
they seed it enough then you'll start
seeing it more the story will morph
it'll say good well many people do
believe he was actually black they'll
passively say it yeah then later on
they'll say well originally incorrectly
you know called white in history books
may toven a black man actually did this
and they change history yeah did I
change it sure they say there is no
death of bizarre theories on the
Internet
the latest one to hop onto the bandwagon
is none other than a theory about the
greatest composer of all time Ludwig van
Beethoven we all know Beethoven as the
famous German composer and the
mastermind behind several popular
classical musical pieces like fifth
symphony moonlight sonata
among many others according to a picture
being circulate on the Internet
Beethoven may have been a
lack man and not the white man we have
seen in his portraits now I want to make
absolutely clear
I really wouldn't care if he was wasn't
I'm confused Chinese or Muslim or
whatever right I think it's mean it was
fantastic and I think moonlight sonata
is one of the greatest songs ever
written it's incredible I love that song
and the issue here for me is more about
our people going to be able to change
history
it seems like like what if someone what
if someone found like a famous black
inventor and then changed it you know
and said he wasn't actually black
actually you'd be actually was this
Evette we wouldn't want to do that
either we want to respect the people and
we don't need to change their histories
well Jesus was supposedly a white man
they've certainly changed him to white I
mean do you think the actual Jesus was a
white white guy we know he wasn't yeah
that looks like that looks like me
long-haired they don't call me so Jesus
for nothing that's exactly when oh look
at that
history is written by the victors one of
the most famous people of all time it
was he white doesn't yeah a white guy
but he's portrayed as the whitest of
whites what's interesting is especially
with anime mm-hmm the characters I was I
was I was talking to somebody about this
there was a controversy over ghost in
the shell' when they did the live-action
movie and they'd Scarlett Johansson Ryan
White woman playing motor Co Kusanagi I
think I mean the name right who was
supposed to be Japanese woman and I was
talking to people as a background watch
at fusion I was like actually the whole
show is about people with prosthetic
bodies their brains are cyber eyes dand
downloaded into robot bodies and so she
could literally be anything yeah and one
of the things I was reading about this
was that III started thinking why is it
then in so many anime shows there's
blonde hair blue-eyed white people like
Naruto for instance he's got blond hair
and blue eyes
really yes he does Edward Elric has
hazel eyes and blond hair and so I
there's a lot of shows like this and
what I read was actually too many
Japanese people they don't look at the
characters being drawn aren't white
they're being drawn like Japanese some
of them they do they do have white
characters they do have black characters
but it's it's white people who look at
the art and because the art is actually
fairly illed
find like the facial features in the
eyes right white people look at it and
think that looks like me
Japanese people look at and say that
looks like me right so it's like people
assign their assumptions like their
biases about what they look like to the
thing they're seeing so anyway I thought
that was rather interesting especially
in this context that now apparently
people want race to be the most
important prominent thing but now what
but let's compare it though me in the
Middle East
Jesus was probably Middle Eastern he was
thank you yeah now now go to this
article here we got Beethoven was born
in Germany probably why a German couple
okay well I mean classically speaking
Germans are I mean I'm I'm not saying
that there isn't minority groups in
Germany born we could be wrong like we
could it could have been that it was a
minority group that he was born to this
is the photo they're claiming proves
that he's black what is the image I
guess oh this is this is it here
apparently yeah he looks like Bill
Murray there Bill Murray yeah that looks
like Bill Murray yeah yeah he was a
little bit like Bill Maher got a bill
thing going on yeah yeah we'll just call
him bill bill Tobin yeah he was born in
1770 1770 not a lot of interracial
migration as far as I know and you know
people just want to believe it they do
yeah cuz we're rewriting all the history
now it's fun it's really yeah so it's
interesting because I'm not gonna read
what they say I'll read it they say Oh F
no I'm burnin asked down Ludwig von
Beethoven the musical genius was really
black and his whole time they tried to
paint him as white I'm tired of black
people and history being erased and
whitewashed oh wait hold on I'm sorry
wait a minute and Uncle Ben just got
cancelled and Jemima just got canceled
so all these all these figures in our in
our everyday life yeah I don't
necessarily like Aunt Jemima syrup but
I've seen him like oh I know about it I
like real maple syrup myself
but it's like I don't care what like
it's it's a thing it's a prominent thing
but they're they're getting rid of it
completely they're not even whitewashing
God it's just gone objection
go on to him objection yeah yes please
hit me Aunt Jemima syrup is awful okay
and they and they and and well it's more
like corn syrup yeah right right I was
watching mrs. Butterworth's commercials
from back in the day okay and I I guess
mrs. Butterworth's was always corn syrup
and the commercials they would run is
they'd be like mrs. Butterworth's runs
slower you know twice or that the
leading brand runs twice as fast as mrs.
Butterworth's and mrs. Butterworth's
pours real slow and I'm like first of
all it's because it's not maple syrup
right and maple syrup is more liquid
yeah and who cares it pours slower weird
yeah but but yeah so I guess the engine
- syrup is when they started doing just
corn syrup with flavoring and you know
what maybe her name doesn't need to be
on it maybe they can you know what you
do get something for menthe maple pure
the good stuff
sounds good of that dan Jemima she
deserves it yeah whatever man but yeah
it's all part of this weird nonsensical
framework that's what it is
you you you Beethoven is is a great
person he's gotta be black and Jemima
now honestly the the model and the woman
who apprehended it sounds like a great
woman
yeah but they don't want her imagery
anymore she achieved the American dream
man I don't I just don't were them that
but do you mean like a millionaire for
her time or do you mean a millionaire
based on inflation that's what I've read
because she was a millionaire back in
like 1900
it said that she became a millionaire
she was she was traveling the road she
was like selling the product people
loved her she Daisy she was she was
traveling the country like sellin
selling her flower mix that instant
pancake stuff it's like that's awesome
this weird is all weird yeah get it down
yeah it's I don't understand
like how is it not racist to get rid of
all these figures that no one had issues
with especially when they were like like
like what what I want to say like the
the first person to like rise and show
boom look someone that rose from slavery
and made it right like awesome
like that's the kind of story we need
more of like why would we try to get rid
of that completely I don't understand I
wonder if it's just because they hate
America I'm starting to think it is
because if she achieved the American
dream and the American dream now is
really really bad
like and we don't believe that anyone
can achieve it that's why would you hold
her up as a paradigm you know what
that's uh that's interesting you should
say that because I watched the rasz
article or res right you know warlord of
Chad so the warlord of chaz it's funny
that that that's what people are calling
him but hotep jesus did an interview
with with Raz today and I watch it and
it was it was enlightening Raz is not
what they portray him as he he he said
all lives matter right he did you know
he said we're all one race yeah okay
right I was like awesome man and he's a
successful man he he knows what he's
doing right he's smart it's clearly Pro
to a right yeah he's working to make
real change he doesn't want to get rid
of the police it's he said a lot of
things that I was not expecting he's not
the figure that they want him to be but
he's like no I want to make real change
I'm really trying to like you know help
these people and that's when I you know
I see this video I there was this one
floating around where some dude beat up
somebody and Raz was there and Raz
didn't want to fight the guy other guys
other guy told like it was like I'm not
gonna listen to you I'm just gonna beat
him up and start beating him up and it's
like see I can see I see now now that if
I've just heard him speak you know today
it was like that was the first time I've
heard from his his own voice you know
and I was like all right wow that's
pretty respectful like he's actually
trying to make legitimate changes he's
you know it's man I I there's so much
about it but it's like he is not the
left's ideal person he's strong yeah and
assertive he he's a successful black man
it's
he's proven that you know you can rikes
the victimhood narrative right exactly
to me like he is also living the
American dream
yeah I don't think they're gonna like
him either once they figure out what
he's doing which is really interesting
yep
what kind of narrative is that to feed
to the people who follow you that's not
nice
I never liked this growing up I didn't
like this you know during Occupy Wall
Street when they would you know and
there's this one thing I've brought up a
lot if I agree with them mm-hmm then
they use everything about my past as an
excuse that's proof and if I disagree
with them then they just regard my
entire history so during during Occupy
Wall Street I would often have
conversations with people and if I agree
with them they would say things like I
remember one conversation I had what
they were like you see man you are the
perfect example of what's wrong with
this system right you're smart you're
hard-working you came down here you
stand up what you believe in yeah but
because you come from a family it
doesn't fit that norm they will hold you
back and that's why you are are you know
that you didn't succeed in school and
that's why you're here with us and I'm
like sure and then a week later I get
featuring all these magazines and what
do they say Tim Poole was what is white
and born with a silver spoon in his oh
I'm sure he's a trust-fund kid and that
proves everything Wow and then there
were people there who knew me and they
were like you know he's homeless right
like he sleeps in the park and they're
like that's not true he's just like an
adventurer
you know he's just he's messing around
and they're like no I'm pretty sure he's
broke like we had to buy him food and
he's been getting the bagels out of like
the bin like the rest of us yeah yeah
and he smells kind of weird but their
narrative was shattered ironically it
still holds true they think oh yeah they
couldn't handle it when I was a high
school dropout sleeping in a park with
with nothing it was perfect for their
narrative their social justice narrative
yeah you know this country can't accept
you know your families and true love but
then as soon as I was successful you're
white dude you're white backwards yes
because all of a sudden I was like the
American Dream is possible I'm proof no
you're not you're lying for you and it's
not that kind of and Terry Crews for
example we spoke about him earlier it's
like what do they say to him I mean he
says well no I'm I'm successful I'm
doing all this I believe in the American
dream oh well your traitor your traitor
- no they call them worse things than
the worse yes they do I
wasn't gonna say this right Mary that's
not make me so angry scratch the surface
of it but it's I I what absolutely
look man you know when I hear people
talk about wanting to punch a racist in
the face man I feel I feel it I hear you
but you I can't live that way
you can't just walk up to a random
person and punch him yeah as much as I
get that feeling I can I guess I get
really mad really really mad because
I'll tell you what I'm not gonna name
drop anybody but I know some people who
are Filipino some people who are black
Mexican and some of the smartest people
hardest-working people successful people
and like we mentioned you know you can
go on Twitter and find some really
really great people of all different
races that you will agree with that you
know are really smart and then when I
hear people say stupid stereotypes about
people based on their race the first
thing that hits me is like bro you're
talking about my friend right
no stop disrespecting people you know
you have a problem with people because
they act like morons I got no problem
ragging on an tyfa who are white neck
like morons all right you want to talk
about gangbangers won't talk about you
know criminals burglars whatever anybody
from any race can be this thing and we
can we can rag on people for their
behavior all day and night but I it's
it's man is it is I have nothing but
contempt and utter disdain I've gotten
all of arguments with like race realists
yeah and they and I feel like they can't
back their arguments up because it's
just it's this thing these things are
really really difficult to prove but
what I can't stand is on one side of the
coin you have the blank slate people
yeah everyone is completely the same and
they're all developed by a construct but
then you have the race then you have the
realest people who are like everyone is
a complete product of their genetics
that can't be changed it's almost like
it's somewhere in the middle and I'm
like a bell curve Oh like most of the
people are in the middle of that and
don't agree with either side you know
you know it's crazy
Thanks the motivations of humans are
probably like 99.9% identical yep same
emotion same driving make Nora me Mei
food and make more of me yeah yeah
exactly yeah and so when you understand
like what humans really do then
everything is derivative of that and
and it's about our survival and
expansion and there are people who crave
power there are people who don't there
are leaders and there are followers and
there are smart people in there stupid
people and I think it's absurd that the
blank slate people are like genetics
play no role in any of these things it's
like now listen man let's let's be
completely real genetics absolutely
plays a role in your height your hair
color eye color your fast twitch and
slow twitch muscles and yes there
probably is a correlation between race
and many of these features including
intelligence right however you what you
you you get these people on the far left
who refuse to even discuss the concept
of probability right and so I defer to
Sam Harris the actual brain scientist
neuroscientist right and he had this
conversation saying it's likely that it
plays a role but I just think that
nurture plays a substantial role
slightly a probably a much bigger role
yeah
you can program humans you can teach
them you can develop them you can and
and they and they strive to succeed so
you I feel there was a story about a
chess grandmaster and he apparently like
I'm gonna you know ruin the story except
I'm not gonna get it perfect he contacts
another chess grandmaster a female and
he's like or I think they were chess
masters or scientists I think they're
both scientists and he's like I know how
to create geniuses so let's have kids
together and then raise them to be
geniuses and then the kids all grew up
to be like the top female Grandmaster
chess players okay and so they were
asked to do the same thing with adopted
kids and he was like I'm too old I can't
do it but while it's not perfect because
it was literally the children of two
geniuses a small sample size I still
think it's fair to point out that there
is a nurture role in this and I can
speak from personal experience and the
choices made by people growing up in my
neighborhood the difference between me
and the kid who grew up you know just a
few houses down or a block away from me
it's like my mom was was you know
tutoring us in home schooling us extra
yeah you know and you'd the funny thing
is though okay when I when I when I
talked to some of my more right-leaning
friends they're like Tim that's not fair
your mom's Korean and I'm like aw come
on like Korean mom tutoring your kids
and being very studious and everything
and I'm like no
but I can't argue it I mean my mom is
from st. Louis or or something like that
was really important I I don't think
that actually I don't think the reason
that my mom was very studious and wanted
to be a teacher had anything to do with
with race or ethnicity right I think it
had to do with more being a mom and
wanting to have an active role and and
yeah yeah and that's why there are other
people in the neighborhood of different
races who had similar behaviors and
their kids are successful without
name-dropping anybody I know some kids
whose parents were very supportive and
and and pushed them and andro and and
like particularly one individual who was
black and became extremely successful
there are people in my neighborhood
that's of all different races so anyway
I don't wanna go on a huge rant about
this I think we get the point
but yeah men oh I put up by saying this
I feel that anger when I hear you know
racists say stupid things about people
because it reflects on my friends you
know and I don't like it I don't like it
at all I am a hundred percent with you
man but I'll tell you what I feel the
same way you're not gonna win an
argument by walking up to him and
screaming and smack him in the face
you're gonna you're gonna invite them
over for dinner with your friends of
different races yep and then like like
Darrell Davis did yeah I love this story
man yeah he's awesome he would agree he
met this guy who was a white supremacist
who they were very apprehensive of him
and he and he knew that this guy was a
huge rock and roll fan and he was like I
can remember whose car it was it was a
famous you know a classic car
convertible and he was like hey man he's
like you know I'm a musician I know the
guys got the car you want to see it and
this white supremacist was was like no
way you're gonna bring me the car and
he's like I got you and then that Alton
this guy was like this is the coolest
guy ever you know and then he realized
they're their people and they came
together and Darrell Davis is a legend
man this dude is incredible yeah if you
don't know who he is you shouldn't you
should do amazingly inspirational dude
yes and so we did an event in Philly and
he showed up and I tell you what man he
brought with him a chest full of Klan
Garba oh really yeah and symbols and
stuff roofies he was at but but kind of
yeah yeah yeah over 200 people that's
amazing and and the amazing thing is
that he did it by just hanging out with
him
showing him that we're all human but not
even really we all have emotions we all
want to have a good time you you you you
think you you think it's like him
thinking to himself I'm gonna do my best
to dear attica lies his people it wasn't
yeah it was him literally being like you
want to hang out and then they would sit
down and talk about rock and roll yeah
and these guys were like this dude's rad
and then he was saying that like
eventually these guys start to think
about it and they're like hey man these
things I'm hearing don't represent my
friend and I don't like hearing these
things Darrell's cool
yeah and that was it and I'm like then
it's spread love love spread man that's
you know even even if you like even if
you think the worst things about people
and you and you have assumptions and you
want to focus on certain issues I just
tell you man we have to learn to live
together on this planet yes we do
there's not gonna be a situation where I
mean maybe China goes and just like
sorry
you know purging people but they're not
gonna win either we're we all live on
earth we're all humans and I know it's I
know it's silly because different
cultures are so you know can't overlap
they can't work together right like we
we are America and China and man mmm but
I'll tell you what
China's way of life and I'm the Chinese
Communist Party's way of doing things
cannot survive on this planet without
them doing a truck committing atrocities
the American Way of life welcomes all
people and there's problems but we have
to make sure we maintain that American
culture first and foremost and then
under that umbrella of the American
Constitution life liberty the pursuit of
happiness
everybody can thrive and be happy and
learn to live together you know what Tim
I'm gonna spin the UFO there we go let's
do it this is for you Tim now that we
just like no one else beautiful heart I
love you all
but this for you man is why I love spin
the UFO is why I love America man cuz
think about it no but I mean this the
way the way the Chinese Communist Party
runs things it's you the way a lot of
these countries with their like I don't
think so many of these left us
understand how racist so many countries
are like I mean literally it's very
difficult to move their journey of
America where we actively fight against
it to the point where we have lunatics
running through the streets thinking
they're fighting but they're making
things worse they're actually becoming
racist themselves we right we fight
racism so hard we have people fighting
racism and
doesn't exist anymore that's great
yeah it's getting bad that's why we have
to keep resisting these people's desire
to have racial pretext in law and
discrimination so I'll put it this way
man they these these far leftists they
like to say to me aren't you a fan of
Star Trek don't you want to live in that
future that's what we're trying to build
and I'm like no you're not do they know
the story though too because San
Francisco he crumbled and then after
they realized it didn't work that way
Star Trek and no Star Trek was like
listen a real future that incorporates a
one-world system we call it earth and
it's the Federation and we travel the
Stars we all live together that means
you can't go and throw a pie in
someone's face for being white that
means you can't start smearing and
insulting white people it means that
even if you meet someone who's white was
a racist you've got to sit down with
them and got to talk to them about why
we're gonna hang out
have a beer have a slice of pizza yeah
and then at the end of it you you you
can't play this this this race tribalism
game like they're playing yep they're
bringing the problems back yep they're I
don't like it I don't either
yeah we're regressing but you know what
man they're taking ground that's scary
right thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune into this channel subscribe hit the
like button or check us out on iTunes
and Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you